all right let's kick it off with another
game that we hoped was going to come
back this year we saw the trailer dead
rising for its out Frank West is back
and it's coming out rather Frank wes is
back and it's coming out actually pretty
soon holiday 2016 and Mike you excited
about this one yeah I'm we were talking
earlier in the pre-show whether they
were going to kind of go back to dead
rising one and two a little bit more you
know you see them getting less reserved
as they go on deck three I had a lot of
fun with but it was a very Western open
world like zombie game I mean based on
what they were going in this that looks
almost like it sunset overdrive kind of
weapons but uh doesn't look like they
have any reservations with this game
yeah see that's just a giant snack stand
that he's driving uh I mean I kind of
hope they're not leaning too hard into
the nonsense of dead rising 3 cuz they
have been worried about that the
question I'm one answered is like how is
the structure gonna work it's two like
very kind of this methodical you go out
for certain amount of time you you're
gonna want to come back with a zom zom
Breck's yeah and then one was like you
gotta keep an eye on that clock yeah
after all the missions just interesting
overarching element that kind of
overshadows everything whereas in three
I you you did have a limited time but it
was like 12 hours yeah it was ridiculous
you didn't have to worry about it if you
didn't play that game longer than 12
hours the crafting looks like it's
coming back obviously the Christmas
aesthetic i like i love anti-christmas
things right I'm not against Christmas
but really I love die hard it's set
during Christmas which but it's not a
Christmas movie yeah I kind of like the
hearing sleigh bells while murdering
Bible these massive flaming snack stand
is great well this is the perfect cake
for you Mike McCready remind me to not
hang out with you Matt Cimber oh yeah I
I go nuts I love a good Christmas game
yeah 2016 this is great when I got a
couple of months away for it
you